joining me now is glenn greenwald
pulitzer prize-winning journalist uh
glenn
so we're sending more than
three billion dollars in aid ukraine we
have no idea how much of it's actually
you know going into that black hole how
much of it might end up in the hands of
russia
but i know there are a lot of americans
here who say what about us
yeah you know as we've discussed before
the question that never got asked from
the very beginning of the us role in
this conflict is how does u.s
involvement in this war in increasingly
escalatory ways
risking confrontation with russia or
just opening the coffers of our
government and sending billions of
dollars into as you said this black hole
benefit the lives of the of american
citizens which ought to be i would think
the primary if not the only question
that gets asked when we think about
which policies to support at the united
states government engaging in that
should be the question
why does the you do american citizens
have a strong interest i understand why
russian russia does but why do american
citizens have a strong interest in who
governs regions in eastern ukraine
and you know the amazing thing about it
laura is that when obama got asked on
his way out why didn't you do more to
arm ukraine he said the reality is
ukraine will always be of a vital
interest to russia but never will be for
us and therefore will never risk a
confrontation with moscow over ukrainian
sovereignty that's just the reality and
now you're not allowed to say that
well in case people thought that glenn
this was kind of coming to an end i mean
u.s involvement well think again
how long can the u.s maintain the level
and pace of this military support for
ukraine
i well we have the capacity to do this
for a long time the most important thing
right now
is maintain the unity so far so good
800 million dollars greenlit today
and on top of the billions uh already
earmarked uh for ukraine
but
all these folks the neocons on
television other democrats saying this
is going to be
years
not months but years why are they so
confident this is going to go on for
years or is it wishful thinking
it's wishful thinking and i think the
reason they're confident that their wish
will be fulfilled is because they're
doing everything to ensure that the war
goes on forever you know it seemed clear
from the start that the real us strategy
was to try and trap russia into the kind
of war that the u.s got embroiled in
afghanistan where you fight an
insurgency that can never end the
country gets destroyed the people of
that country suffer but so does the
invader because
the u.s spent two trillion dollars there
only to walk out 20 years later as if
they had never been there when the
taliban waltz right back in and of
course the u.s also helped trap the
soviet union in afghanistan in in the in
the 80s by feeding what became al-qaeda
and so we have this long list of
historical examples where we fought
these wars or where we've armed and
funded
groups that fought against our enemies
and usually what ends up happening is
the country gets destroyed the people
suffer people far away from the
battlefield get to feel strong and
purposeful by cheering it on and saying
we have to stand up to putin but nobody
in the united states benefits except for
weapons manufacturers the pentagon and
the u.s security state and that's
absolutely what's happening here
glenn it's great to see you tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else